The quantity 2y minus 3z times the quantity 3x plus 4 is correct. Fantastic work
for getting that one right. Now, I know we haven't covered negative signs yet,
so don't worry if you didn't get it right. Let's see how we could do this. I can
see that both this term and this term share a y, and also, they're both
divisible by 2. So, 2y must by my greatest common factor. If I divide 2y into
6xy, I'm left with 3x. And if I divide 2y into 8y, I'm left with positive 4.
Here, this term is negative and this term is negative. The negative 9 and
negative 12 share a negative 3 as a common factor. They also share a z. Now, I
want to think about what two terms should go in here. What number times negative
3z will give me negative 9xz? That must be positive 3x. Then, I think about what
number times negative 3z will give me negative 12z. This must be positive 4. And
this is great. This first term and the second term share a common factor of 3x
plus 4, so we can factor again. So, this 3x plus 4 is here for one of my factors
and 2y minus 3z is my other factor. And again, this line should make sense
because if we distribute 2y, we'll get 2y times 3x plus 4, our first term. And
then if we distribute negative 3z, we'll have negative 3z times 3x plus 4, our
second term. So, this is our last finaled factored form.